hey guys how's it going so i'm so
excited to share this video with you
this is from comic-con now i've been
doing this show on youtube.com aol on
tech called hardwired where we've been
traveling around and talking about
wearable tech so for comic-con we had
the idea of coming up with a superhero
and a costume and somehow we got stan
lee involved so he helped mentor me into
becoming a superhero and we did a panel
and all this stuff together so instead
of me explaining it to you i'm going to
share with you the video that we shot at
comic con capturing this whole entire
thing in addition to that we also shot
this fun origin story with stan and to
unlock it once aol on tech gets 20 000
subscribers they will post the video so
go over subscribe so we can see this
video because i actually haven't even
seen it yet anyway i'm gonna stop
talking here's the video and i'll see
you later bye hey guys it's justine it
is 7am i'm here at comic-con getting
ready for a huge day because i'm about
to unveil to you guys the hard-wired
superhero that i've been working on with
stan lee i mean he has mentored me every
step of the way who better to help me
become a superhero than stan lee i mean
look at this this is me
good morning
there's so many people here and i know
they're definitely here for the big
hardwired superhero costume reveal
stanley obviously i mean look at him
i think probably my favorite superhero
of all time is iron man and
i mean i'm
almost iron woman
except i don't think i'm very strong
the way i am drawn i don't look quite
enough like brad pitt
the world sure is lucky that it's got us
here fighting for him
i think we should have been saying
something clever if this man has been
photographed
so the show is all about wearable tech
so we decided to take all of this
wearable tech that we've done from the
show and turn it into a superhero
costume
kind of taking all the elements from
every episode we put them into the
costumes so of course i love video games
so i was like we need to have a holster
for my xbox controller so we've got that
awesome and i have like a verizon wi-fi
so i'll have like a basically like a
walking hot spot so we just got done
talking to the press hung out with stan
it was so awesome and now we're heading
to the panel to reveal the hardwired
costume officially so if you need to get
around comic-con this is really the only
way to do it we're heading into the
panel now
hello hi okay
so these are my normal human clothes
we're heading backstage and we're gonna
finish up getting dressed and then we're
gonna head out to reveal to the world
hard water
[Music]
guys stan is right behind me we're about
to head on to
[Applause]
she uh has a new show coming to aol
called hardwired anybody knows how to
make somebody a superhero to make their
dreams come true to make this reality
real obviously stan is the man stan was
like don't worry justine we got this
meet me at comic-con we'll have your
costume and you will be ready to take on
the wearable tech world by storm all
right it's go time it's time to
introduce to the world hardwired
[Applause]
where do you want me to go um you know i
thought all this wearable tech you'd be
like set to go here you can take my mind
if you like okay all right hey guys
how's it going so yeah this is the
costume i mean this is amazing i've
always wanted to be a superhero so this
is real life do you have any advice for
her you know um
you being who you are yeah see if you
can meet robert downey jr it won't be
any harm
with the help of stan lee i am now a
superhero i think you look great
maybe a little overdressed maybe you
could knock off half of the costume and
defend
but that's up to you
it's up to you and the fans
all right
we just got off the panel of stanley it
was absolutely amazing we debuted to the
world the
hardwired ijustine my name yeah and i'll
send someone together
[Music]
natural born superhero
what kind of soup do you have broccoli
can i get that actually great thank you
i don't even think he noticed that this
was a camera is this even legal